yeah welcome to this video round seven
of the candidates in London and as
announced two days ago I am on site and
did watch this round live yeah it was
very nice to to not only have a webcam
or something to watch but to really be
them and I always always like to do with
it those events if possible it's
unfortunately in Germany you don't have
that much of a chance to do that and
okay this is really an outstanding
tournament so it's it's it's great to be
here and to get to have a look at the
players I also never saw a couple of
those guys live I have seen some some of
them live but not cancer for example and
it's a very interesting thing to watch
that if you enter the the playing hall
and players are seated it's four minutes
or five minutes into the round starts
and there are maybe 20 20 guys from the
press doing photos and 19 of 20 are
making pictures of Carlton they simply
ignore all the other guys really they do
the odd photo but it's like 90 percent
of attention is on him so this is also
something you need to take into account
he's got all this thanks to to to handle
in addition of course he's he gets paid
well for all this but still some other
guys who are not much weaker in terms of
chess they don't don't have those yeah
those obligations to me talk to the
press and whatever okay still I want to
do a video and I often announce that the
videos planned to be short
and at the end I'll do again one our
thing but I really hope this will be
shorter because I'm so tired I I needed
to get out really early get the flight
and so on
so let's see what happened today we have
got Yvonne Chowk against Sevilla let's
go through all the games and do this
really quickly we have a scotch opening
um in my before five repertoire series I
recommended this offbeat move which I
still like but of course in those
super-high level tournaments they play
the mainstream openings and the
mainstream lines and this line is a very
reliable of course Yvonne Chaka Khan c6
and play d5 them most ambitious line
here Queen to e7 this is important it's
it's less good to to move the night so
that it can be kicked again this queen
is heaven
forces white on on the bed square with
the zone Queen and this allows after
Knight d5 see for this pinning move
Bishop
a6 something been really long debate if
this move is better or you should be a
six is better at the moment Bishop by
sixes the more fashionable move arg3 new
six black wants to play Bishop to g7 and
and take the pawn and white needs to
protect this this is why when b3 and
there should be two and now long castles
black and also Castle short as more than
one interesting line and now Bishop to
g2 what was really crazy that even
Jacques spent like look need to take it
back look at this one hour forty eight
and then he took like forty minutes for
the smooth
which is really crazy in a way because
this is so all known known theory and
for some reason he took ages to to play
this move so it'll also took took a
while for rupee eight I think one point
why even shock thought for long maybe
was that somehow he hadn't anticipated
this line and he sort of knew what was
coming and tried to find some
alternative but failed
yeah well rook e8 this is a tech c5 for
the third time and white cannot really
protect it move like f4 for for instance
runs into f6 and look at this
the problem is that white is much behind
and development he still got this night
on its initial square hasn't canceled
yet so what needs to quickly get out of
the center and now black took e5 and
this some it's a forced line now we have
an exchange on e5 and C takes d5 so um
quite uncommon all the material
transformation where after Bishop takes
takes a look we takes ivory captured and
black took on d5 also let's pass on what
blacks got rook and two pawns
no not musics two pawns against them two
minor pieces so from a purely
mathematical point of view black is okay
and the problem of this this endgame in
general he is it's very very difficult
for both sides to do anything
the problem is white simply yeah his
stupid pawns down on the on the Queen
side he needs to watch blacks pawns and
tries to attack them maybe winning one
of them this is the only way to make
progress
when one of the pawns and black must be
cautious that he doesn't lose one of the
pawns and if that is happening they're
simply not much to play form it's
possible that even shook somehow
stumbled into this and tried on the way
to find something else to fight he is a
fighter but sometimes you you simply
don't get the positions he had simply
very difficult for both sides to make
any progress and sevilla also didn't
have so much choice him he needed to
take on e5 yeah well they played a
couple of moves sorry
and basically this is just shuffling
around and he had draw a greet it's a 30
millisecond they cannot agree before
that yeah I can show you that this
endgame is very difficult to do anything
with I had played this some time ago in
a correspondence game and with black and
I analyzed it in some depth it's simply
very very difficult to get anything with
both colors so the draw is a rather
logical result okay next game Gelfand
Kramnik kramnik certainly needs to win
at some point a game otherwise he's out
of it but like against Gelfand is of
course not easy
yeh Gelfand allows the nerves oh he also
plays Knight f3 and Gees but we got
animism and we got the rubenstein the
cup of variation this Kramnik already
had played against the job of when he
had a quite convenient position which
still ended in a draw
of course this is solid and very well
playable for black it's so difficult to
to do anything in terms of winning
chances
I think Bromley played a rather
interesting setup let's see everything's
normal here and now played Queen to be
aid and this is a new idea at least
everyone at this unsighted reach that it
is a new idea I didn't check it now with
the database but they all said that this
new Kramnik also and Gaffa and also so
they should know better - about this
yeah Queen b8 it's quite interesting the
ideas after here that like is attacking
the bishop and threatening this year
damaging the pawn structure is white
they play such a nothing move you can
take here and now must take with the
pawn because it's the same because white
doesn't want this pawn structure to to
be damaged so Bishop e3 was played and
now Bishop d6 an interesting move
attacking age to simply very simple but
it's effective black is threatening to
take here and to take yeah and Goffin
didn't find anything better than g3
which looks a bit ugly doing this kind
of hand shadow move with the bishop on
d3 edge weakens this Knights position
and the King side but it's still not
much happening it's a 6 to control b v
square and now girlfriend took on f6 and
centralize the noid he simply wanted to
um yeah wrap the game up and play in row
I think with this g3 and so on it's not
like white can can do much now here
black in fact and could easily draw the
game I mean this
it's really dry with rooks e7 at some
point we've got opposite colored bishops
and there's simply nothing happening
so this kramnik would have played I
think in some some other circumstances
here he wanted to fight and strangely
enough instead of a normal move he came
up with okay he took he took that first
okay here it's this position here in
fact Gaffin could have taken on f6
but after f5 this seems fine for black
in the in the comedy room I actually
made this suggestion but it is not so
great black has got this important move
which which covers this and you can you
can just cover him it's nothing nothing
happening okay he just took on c1 and
did this is the position I was getting
at here black can play all kinds of
simple things he can take here and draw
I can play him some other simple
strengthening moves like Bishop defy for
example which is after this the position
but black can easily play on at least he
can fight he however played the move
Knight to e8 and in fact Kramnik after
the game when he learned what what now
was possible he couldn't really explain
why he played ninety eight I think one
reason was simply to to avoid the draw
he wanted to to fight in some way the
problem is that now I'm gelfand could
have won the game just like that with
Knight F to g5 and I mean it's not
exactly rocket science to
to see that it is dangerous I mean Devon
also saw it would they they had a press
conference and so on but there was some
big miscalculation he mainly looked at
the other night move which is
interesting it also just attacking him
aged six and he calculated Bishop g6
then he spent lots of time on this and
this is actually working but on night
two to g5 this night um yeah this is
actually also good now that I look at it
what is black doing this is working yeah
he saw some ghost I'm not quite sure I
cannot exactly recollect the press
conference but he saw some some problems
with those moves this is also very
strong this is what was what we analyzed
in the in the in the commentary room h6
and Queen h5 attacking f7 and what is
like supposed to do now you can take but
now this is really a lot IAM age seven
f7 and now there's multiple ways this is
also excellent but the simplest is this
and b7 is also hanging black has no way
to defend this and this b7 and g7 so in
this position both night moves would
have been excellent
this is outright a winning and this is
at least dangerous however in the game
he played this which really produced a
really loud disappointing noise from the
from the commentators because they were
really looking forward to to do this to
continue with this attacking and taking
possibilities yet after this there's
simply nothing
the rest of the game was basically a
trade of pieces down to a king and pawn
and game even which which is dead though
simply nothing to do you can always have
a look at this and this end game
sometimes there are some tricks involved
but here the King important game is just
it's just just nothing alright so next
game Aronian against gree shock queen's
indian and in fact the classical line
here was g3 and bishop to be seven this
has been played really many times here
the most common mouthless actually am
yeah rook c1 or Queen c2 um quite
surprisingly Aronian plays Knight d5
here he has played this before I'm
pretty sure on but it's a bit of a
special for him like can exchange two
paths of minor pieces now and this is
actually something that should be um
something that black welcomes but it
didn't really materialize here c5 Knight
Bank and this happened
yeah and now black cannot really take on
d4 this looks to a very one-sided kind
of position with just drop key one
coming up P 1 P 2 just a lot of pressure
on this M this is why Greece chakra went
back to e7 prevented that and here
Aronian played this interesting the
maneuver just attacking the pawn on g7
and yeah what that cannot cannot play g6
this looks
and simply to Toulouse on the long
diagonal this is what he must play it's
not clear that this is so great actually
we've got a bit of a weak Bishop on his
heaven but this is some counter player
who shook aims for some counter-attack
maybe with f4 at some point and black
has got quite some influence on the
centre the problem for widest it's it's
a nice structure with this weakness here
but those two pieces are simply useless
the knight on f3 years ages away from d5
and it really wants to go to d5 and the
bishop is completely useless I think he
played played this really well now
before intending c5 and after King h8 he
really went for it with d5 setting up at
least on some problems for me shocked
with slow play um it wouldn't have
amount to much anyway so take stakes and
deform the idea was that if black takes
with the night you can take him and get
a position which favors white because of
the better pawn structure ephors what
guruship redness is also stronger 94 and
95 so the knight on c5 covers this
vulnerable ecig square 9 to b5 Queen b6
and Quincy form and here there was quite
some optimism about White's chances in
the in the analysis room and I would say
also was pretty optimistic about
our onehans chances here but somehow
grew shock managed to keep this position
together as usual he's down on time we
know that's I came of course he also
could have played 90 d5 playing more
yeah
with with compensation not trying to get
upon back this was also an interesting
alternative maybe stronger this night a
for was maybe a bit too simplistic yes
we see now like an exchange some pieces
and it still looks good for white I mean
this is weak this is a weakness but okay
blacks got an extra pawn and it takes a
while to get it back and white needs to
get it back at some point in five yeah
making some room for the king and like
it's looking for counter play on the
Kings side a f4 was an important move to
get something on White's King yeah now
White's really must be careful a bit
with this f3 pawn somewhat obstructing
the King position this is the important
maneuver the Bishop to e5 will have a
very unstable position there and that's
maybe ideas to to get some attack as
black the time was some now really no
Felicia but what he managed to to keep
it together and here he's got this idea
Ruka eight to a for capturing the porn
h5 again now the black king is
approaching this is some color plate and
this is the last precise move which
attacks the pond and if white now takes
on a3
it didn't happen he played Bishop e6 but
if white now takes this rook f8 King
here and black takes the pawn with with
an equal position in the game we played
Bishop to b6 which is also very simple
just a line like this is a dead wrong
look end game with the equal material so
draw for a draw for Aronian he maybe had
some chances but it was never really a
so obvious how I could could improve
okay so let's do parson raja baath we
have a Bishop b5 line in the Sicilian
the Russell Nemo and a success our job
of some main move
he played this already many times
Carlson takes and here with E 5 tries to
attack blacks confirmation he wants to
have some weak pawns to play against and
in fact this happens this Knight g6
plate and now Lex got an isolated double
bond which is ugly but in return blacks
got a very nice central formation here
like it's got three pawns on the fifth
rank and this is strong he is really
controlling lots of squares and what's
the weakness of course it's if
and cosplay some in a very
straightforward fashion here text is
born directly even with this move the
problem with this is of course those two
pieces are very far away from the King
and black of course you can see already
has got some tendencies to to go against
the King so it will be a very sharp
sharp game the job of played Queen to e7
protecting the pawn it was hanging after
all and now the question is how does
white make some progress here and I
think what he wanted to do is he wanted
to attack the pawn on c5 once more with
the Queen like this from c3 our e3 the
problem is if you move the Queen now
there's Bishop g5 intending to damage
your structure this is what cards played
c4 just controlling the square yeah rook
to e8 logical opposition move look
against the Queen Queen e2 getting out
of the default and Bishop to c8 yeah and
now it's really difficult for white to
make any substantial progress
you only have one target
this is c5 and this is why I call the
places so straightforwardly it doesn't
have a real other plan
just to text this and the job of cannot
afford to give it up so he plays ephraim
queenie fall right in the middle of the
board and now came to h8 were a job of a
good multipurpose move giving white um
yeah now a choice what's what supposed
to do here what cousin did is probably
probably not the best
it's may be possible that white must
play an h3 here which is rather ugly
looking move but it's it's maybe a
necessary move the idea is that Bishop
to g4 is a problem and this obviously
prevents it still it doesn't move you
don't like to make because it's an
attacking target in the long run black
can even go rook f5 to h5 and try to
sacrifice it is dangerous but maybe he
needs to do it the thing is have a look
at the game he played rook e1 Bishop g4
now in a pin and white cannot really
accept this pin for long so he played
rook to d2 out of the pin and here for a
job of plate in a very straightforward
fashion but it seems to be yeah just
just the good way to play he took and
detect the queen with the knight to H
form simply attacking this piece and
what is the Queen supposed to do now
Carlton played the maybe most natural
looking move Queen to e form putting it
just in the middle of the board
centralization the problem with this
movement it looks nice but it loses he
really had to go to age three maybe to G
form but Queen to h3 the thing is in
comparison to the game after f3 g 392
quite funny to put the spite on G - why
does got hooked reform and now this is a
very unclear position um I'm not quite
sure how to assess it the computers it's
not a big help it just gives the typical
0 0 0 what I do believe is that probably
why it is still ok here it looks a bit
shaky with
a queen on a tree but damn it cannot be
trapped or anything the thing is the
alternative which is what what - played
in the game is just not working
f3 this is played by raja baath g3 no
choice and then 92 and then now the
problem is this rook is hanging and what
are you doing with this rook if you move
it away which is normal that's a rook t1
there's Queen e6 and the fun thing is
that this is really a completely losing
now queen adria and the knight move on
night to h4 Queen to g2 this is not
defensible anymore
why just simply dead lost you cannot
prevent all this it's funny this is a
fianchettoed not it but it's simply a
matter of stranded pieces on the Queen
side they don't help so what did cards
do he of course at this moment realized
that that he made a big mistake but he
defended as good as possible he
retreated the Knights to maybe get it to
reform and exactly here our job of had a
very good chance to probably win the
game he could have taken now on a one
which he certainly considered Queen
takes and now the very strong move
Bishop c7 maybe he didn't see that one
or misjudge something the problem is you
get the knight the bishop to a5 and make
sure that it gets traded against the
knight on all look let's say and the
very bad bishop being exchanged on this
way is a huge progress from like this is
just an exchange of the problem is why
doesn't get the Knight to e4 which is
the compensation if you would put it
there than the special a5 just winning
another exchange this is a bit too much
okay Y can take c5 but
so it's simply winning this mover would
have won the game I think what a job of
played was also not bad at all it's also
very tempting he played Queen here to
get this threat into the game and this
forces white to play the funny move
Bishop rook e3 again sacrificing the
exchange he must play rook takes f3 I
must have this possibility against Queen
a dream yet here Java took the exchange
this is the right move takes with the
pawn a must yeah this is simply made so
he took with the pawn and now her job of
played the yeah the most obvious moves
in this position maybe it really was a
mistake he is an exchange up and he
always had the chance to play a normal
slow move continuing with the exchange
up let's say Bishop e7 now there are
there are many moves you can play but he
played f2 check which is the most
obvious move in the in the position just
trying to get to White's King this is
also the most that that since witless
suggested when he saw this and he called
it the most natural move some this is
what a job of plate but the thing is
maybe it is not enough there was this
exchange check and then important King
e2 very important if white would go to
g1 for instance there's Queen f6
threatening 22 and before and that's it
white can resigned because of this line
amongst others and it's a checkmate next
move point to move the King must go here
exactly there and okay cousin place the
the best possible defense and by now it
isn't so clear anymore
what is happening here went here to
attack the pawn and white all the way
back maybe this is what the job of dims
really appreciate but here it is Sun
already not so clear what is happening
in this position white is probably okay
again because he's got this monster
night only for coming
black doesn't really have much to do
against this he M retweeted gave checks
and now he tried to h5 as a last try but
our job is also down to one minute it's
it's really in really shaky push it back
to b2 and to here they went for this
repetition it's not possible for for
both sides to get out of the repetition
really black gets too active and white
has no chance to do anything else and
black also must be careful if you play
some second-rate moves you can easily
get in trouble because white has an
excellent night only four and healthy
structure so at the end here a draw was
agreed on this repetition occurred with
the draw as the consequence yeah a good
fighting game but certainly
disappointing for a job of who had an
excellent chance to win and we see that
Carson is not invincible at all it's all
very shaky still this tournament one bad
day like this can easily cost important
points and maybe the desired spot at the
end yet tomorrow
um there's of course the all-important
game Carlton against Aronian the both
both leaders face each other with Carson
playing wide and okay this game is
decisive
the winner will most probably
be the next challenger of course six
rounds after that is something but the
wind would be really huge so it can be
can look forward to that
I'm not so curious to watch this live
tomorrow on site yeah thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it
this time it really was a little bit
shorter but I'm really really Jarrett
and maybe next next video tomorrow will
be a bit longer yeah thanks for watching
and I'll be back soon